maybe we should watch addison ray's mom
doing the whopping
all right [ __ ] oh my god man
again bro every ev everything
nothing is sacred man let me let me fade
this [ __ ] in oh actually
we can't play the music god damn it oh
no but
i could just play the clip yeah you can
play the clip but all right
i'll do cardi's part i don't know
oh look at this gobble gobble that
gobble that [ __ ] oh eat my
ass eat my [ __ ] all right no let's go
with my personal favorite
we just go to the benny hill theme
oh i need to strain this to you hold on
no no i got it i got it
dude
i saw her first tick tock where she was
like addison
addison has to start treating me better
or i'm gonna post the [ __ ] draft that i
have and i was like that's really funny
because you definitely don't have one
you shouldn't have one and it's a funny
joke right
and then the next day she [ __ ] posts
this i'm like jesus [ __ ]
how do you know i mean come on
this is the same [ __ ] as when a mom and
a daughter start a only fans bro this is
the same
[ __ ] i bet you i think there has to be
there's this there's just got to be a
point along the way where you're like
i'm a parent
i'm a parent first and foremost you know
yeah yeah
yeah um parenting first yeah
the joke was funny and then there's a
line
yeah bro can you imagine being like a
like a like maybe like a blue collar
parent and like you do like some
hard-ass labor for like 10-12 hours a
day you get home and your kid is just
like bugged out on tick tock and they're
like dad come do the whop dance he's
like
what the [ __ ] yeah it's like this and
he's like
he's just like shows like the cardi
things like it's funny if we do it
together he's like you're
nine
[Laughter]
i'm learning how to sell houses too yeah
yeah dad
can i have an amazon account so i can do
drop shipping
yeah yeah yeah he's like what the [ __ ]
dude i was thinking about
like drop shipping and how um
it's it's funny that you know
basically we're gonna get to a point
where there's no walmart
there's no nothing it's just gonna be
all like it's going to be like new york
on the internet where it's like all like
the equivalent of like e bodegas and
everyone just drop ships you whatever
yeah everyone's just penny fighting you
know yep well i can do a calculator for
1368.
and everyone has 50 fans yup everyone
has 50 fans
50 fans and uh it's all done with
bitcoin because then you can pay
fractional
you know so then it's like i can i can
drop ship you 12
um uh green peppers for point zero
zero zero nine three three seven bitcoin
yeah
like um guy down the street is doing .90
flat and he's like [ __ ]
fine i'll do 9-0 flat for the 12 green
peppers no
less
yeah yeah yeah that's depressing yeah
anyway and i didn't even know that this
was
her mom he's like i was like hold on i
got to
send my neighbor pictures of my feet
he's one of my fans
as soon as i do this he'll just wire me
a little bit and then i can find and
then i can buy these peppers
he's one of my 50. bruh i hate this man
it's like my top five that's what it's
gonna be they're gonna bring that back
but it's just people that fund your life
yep bro i i hate that the whole
family does this [ __ ] what yeah yeah
yeah yeah what is that better treat me
right or i'm gonna post
is that like her little brother or
something
yeah it's her little brother are they
all doing the whop dance together
uh jesus [ __ ]
like yeah and here's the thing dude now
that tick tock is monetized they make
bank off this [ __ ] look at each one has
like 20 million [ __ ] views
oh yeah bro they got her dad dressing
they got her dad in a dress they're
definitely [ __ ] taking off this [ __ ]
yeah they got they got her dad in a
dress they're made yeah yeah
he's killing it dude yeah no i'm just
saying like
um killing it yeah
yeah slay slavery and serving serve that
look sir my man
is serving um
yeah so yeah that's the haps but um
yeah i saw i was i was that's the haps
with tick tock i remember i was like
looking at one and this guy was like
i just bought this studio um
he was like a flipper and he was like i
just bought this studio apartment in
like kentucky
or something like that yeah and then he
flipped it and he's like and now i'm
gonna sell it for like 50 and i'm gonna
get this loan
and i'm gonna do this with all with my
cash and blah blah and like i looked at
the comments and it's all people arguing
about like the type of loan
and and i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
right that's when i'm on a [ __ ] real
estate subreddit what is this
that's crazy serious like literally like
10 flippers being like that's not
that's not the right way to do it but
what and then there's like 10 other
people that are like
you flippers are ruining the like
housing
prices for us people that you know
hard-working people who actually want to
buy a home
this is the internet bro so you know
like half those people are just like
saying [ __ ] i'm like isn't this the same
app where addison rey's mom is doing the
whop dance yeah am i on that same
app yeah i i've said it before
i'll say it many times it's just too
many
[ __ ] moms on the internet
mom should not be on the internet moms
should be raising their kids they should
have no clue what this is dads too
parents should not be on this [ __ ]
because then
because then it like turns into this
thing where like it's like oh no with
the wap dance it's fun
you can do it too and then it's just
like no parents cannot do these things
they should not be included that's just
that's just is what it is
when we become parents we just can't
participate in
some of this [ __ ] coming up yeah that's
just that's it yeah
some [ __ ] is for the youth and some [ __ ]
is for old people and that i feel like
that's just how it should be
so not be [ __ ] me and my husband have
started our only fans and our daughter
is filming but uh
we take over once we're in the bedroom
i don't know man here's here's the thing
that i was thinking yesterday i was like
why because you know one of one of the
kids in the the sway house he did the
[ __ ] dance and it's
it got like 40 million views right nice
i'm like five years ago dude we were
making fun of cola bran
for [ __ ] his for doing the grind on
me [ __ ] remember that
everyone was talking about how cringy
that is for now and now for some reason
it's fine if you're just cool with it
yeah everybody's cool with it yeah you
know
like oh my god this is next level [ __ ]
dude
[ __ ] your carpet i mean bro because i
feel like
i don't know how to i don't know where
this gets lost
but i feel like at least on vine
there was an element of like you cannot
like do not do some [ __ ] that is not you
like i feel like people kind of sniffed
out integrity
and and i don't maybe i'm wrong you tell
me but i feel like there's like been
some change
where it kind of goes like with the six
nine thing like i feel like
the attitude of like the youngest people
now is if you're getting paid
it's fine and like you know like and and
that's like the number one thing i feel
like a six nine fan says where they go
oh he snitched whatever
he's getting money though so it's cool
yeah you know what i mean like like
there's like this willingness to like
trade like
dude you know it's i feel like it's just
the worst version of would you suck a
dick for a million dollars
yeah that's that's dumb straight dude
question but now
everybody and it's like will you do the
[ __ ] dance for 10k
like yeah i would actually you know yeah
that's the same as like would you get
kicked in the balls for a thousand it's
like yeah
that's not good let's not do this again
we know you would do it
you